hey guys dr. Burke here in this very short video
I'm going to talk about the absolute worst protein
powder that you can consume alright can you take
any can you take well guess what it is now it's
not pea protein it's not even whey protein it is
the soy protein isolate that's the worst protein
you can possibly consume why because first of
all 95% of all soy is genetically modified which
means that it has residue of an herbicide which is
basically Roundup Ready called glyphosate which is
a pretty deadly chemical and so when they modify
this genetically it can even act like a something
like an estrogenic thing to even insects to so
it's it's going to raise your estrogen levels and
decrease your testosterone now women are pretty
much already estrogen dominant and men don't need
any more estrogen so this will lower testosterone
it's in the diet shakes it's in the diet bars it's
in infant formula crazy it's in the artificial
vegan patties that fake meat so you want to stay
away from this protein it's really hard on the
liver and plus it's not fermented fermented like
in tofu tempeh and mezzo this is not fermented
so that means it doesn't digest well and it's
going to be really hard on your liver one day
I am I was at Whole Foods and I saw I saw these
little chicken little nugget things I said oh
that's pretty cool man to order I'm gonna order
some of those right and I noticed when I bought
them they were all the same size and so you start
eating them I'm like this tastes like a weird
piece of chicken it was it was chicken minute of
soy protein isolates and I get home I probably had
two or three and my whole right side of my liver
was like in pain so that was a perfect example or
a demonstration of what I'm not going to do again
so I just wanted to mention this and so put
your comments below and thanks for watching